I don't see what the Santa's path to
Victory is right now on the other hand
if you're DeSantis and you have
sycophants around you as many of these
people often do you might be saying to
yourself the fact that I even have 19.9
and I haven't announced tells me this
may be my shot
sure I could wait until 2028 when I
guess DeSantis would be 48 years old I
could do that
but anything could happen between now
and then my I might be trying with five
percent in 2028 I have 20 right now
maybe Trump gets indicted again or again
or again gets arrested a couple more
times it pulls them off the campaign
Trail Anything could happen maybe I need
to be there